do you remember the early days of grand
theft auto well GTA 5 online is about to
get a blast from the past with a brand
new mode next week I'm Matt and this
gamespot News Update is ready to kick it
old school the first couple games in the
Grand Theft Auto series featured a
top-down view and Rockstar Games has
decided to bring it back in tiny racers
which is basically a new take on GTA
online stunt races however other than
what you're seeing in this footage there
isn't much known about the new mode
saying that we do know when it's coming
and what platforms you'll be able to
play it on tiny racers hits ps4 xbox one
and pc on april 25th all you'll need to
play the new mode is a copy of grand
theft auto 5 on one of those platforms
and PlayStation Plus or xbox live gold
if you're on ps4 or Xbox one we'll keep
you updated as more new modes come to
GTA online so make sure to LIKE and
subscribe however if you want to see
some sweet head shots in an online game
then check out our kill montage from
player unknowns battlegrounds
[Music]